[Música]
tardamos 50 años de esa región
investigando hurgando en el pasado de
pueblos y culturas
como todos los peruanos me siento
orgulloso de haber nacido en esta tierra
que tiene una herencia milenaria
y a lo largo de mi carrera una vez esté
escuchando preguntas sobre he recibido
también preguntas y cuestionamiento
para quién sirve el pasado
sirve de algo al pasado para qué sirve
investigar el pasado vivir de algo del
pasado y esa pregunta me está la nada me
va lejana infancia cuando vivía yo en
una familia de
profesional de policía por maestro está
abogado
y escuchaba siempre es una entrega para
mirar las discusiones y los comentarios
estos mismos peruanos blanco donde pintó
todo el mundo
y escuchaba por supuesto opiniones de
este dinero sobre lo que fue un imperio
fabuloso la utopía de los incas la
igualdad
las obras maravillosas género los incas
las extensiones de los que habían
visitado museo sin terminar de obras de
arte de todas las culturas pero también
escuchando a los otros comentarios
bueno pero y la religión católica no
viene cada serían todos gentiles y
todos hablaban pero desde de ese mundo
maravilloso pero cuando vivíamos en
realidad era a veces un poco diferente y
a veces duras sabías en mi nombre y la
señal la ofensa más directa y rápida que
surge de los peruanos la hemos venido
siempre
solo
pero también bastante de ese lado nativo
no quiere ser tener piel oscura hacer
solo hay que ser un error me abran con
más pino y mientras tanto ascender en la
escala social intenta
éstos eran dilemas que comenzaron a
plantearse en mi vida de niño pero
también en ese pueblo tranquilo donde yo
nací se escuchaban las maravillas o lo
maravilloso relato de leyenda mito de
una época maravillosa donde los animales
hablan con los hombres donde el hombre
se comunicaba con las plantas
todo fue alimentando lo invertimos en un
niño
me parece una herramienta de entender el
mundo explicarme y entender la esencia
de lo que es peruano entender cómo vivía
esta gente les canta y piensa en este
tiempo nebuloso y desde jugar y definir
será todo lo una profesión en práctica
cuando yo decidí hacer eso y bueno mucho
por mí familiarmente y por cómo hacer
por esas
un programa mal mi hambre
pero esto no te agrada
y por supuesto yo estaba totalmente
apasionado por eso que hay más alimento
cuando mi familia está en las ciudades
de trujillo y era un niño fascinado por
ella ver los museos y conocí también
pues también fue un hombre que me llame
muertas y no tendrá ni fe ese interés
maestro amigo mi padre es donde me
mostraba en la vida y tenía una
colección extraordinaria de cerámica en
tu casa no era casi un museo su carpa
pero lo que más me sorprendió que no
solamente eran concretos y no había
dibujo como viniese a puerto y entendí
que el pasado nuestro rolling stones o
song walcott como le llaman está aquí al
operario no sólo puesto en pasado es un
pueblo y que nosotros somos herederos de
ese pueblo
sin imbecilidad dedicarme a la actual
cocina
y bueno
también entendí que en la antología
debía ser un gran dilema
uno de los que tiene residencia está en
el medio de un portento
nuestro hermano 9 en saqueado destruido
desde la época de la conquista para un
tendero piensa o vender los objetos a
quienes coleccionan estas curiosidades
para la gente que política curiosidad de
sus ojos pero estos son testimonios
documentos hay que interpretarlos
leernos y eso se sabe en la universidad
y conocer los primeros textos de
arqueología endémica la arqueología es
una disciplina nuestro un un ejercicio
intelectual de imaginar recrear
reconstruir lo que nuestros la xunta que
unamos y cómo está dedicando comenzar a
cerrar 9 país imprima y entendí que los
museos no solamente debían ser lugares
donde la gente va a satisfacer su
curiosidad para ver cómo estos pueblos
también echó a pique inter presentado en
los núcleos
estudian investigando se dedica a la
antología vine a trabajar ya sabéis lo
extraordinaria y curiosamente o
enfermera el teólogo porque normal tu
vino a trabajar a esta región
los monumentos serán lugares abandonados
donde la gente normalmente me daba la
lectura y no tenía ningún respeto por
ellos
a los 9 la gente que limpian los
alrededores trataban de inventar los
patrones de cultura y el comportamiento
de los blancos o de la gente más
mezquita
tenían vergüenza de ser nativos de ver
brillo salvaje
entonces decidí pero saben que esa
inversión pendiente de cambiar
minuto 4 suerte en fibes este en este
ejercicio profesional de ir respondiendo
algunas de las preguntas que todo el
mundo me planteado el pasado sirve para
algo pide para encontrar su identidad el
pasado sirve para encontrar ese lado que
todavía no logramos conciliar empatado
también puedes permitir para mostrarse
al mundo como un sm con una cultura de
la cual defiendo
technology
y pasaron los años tuve la suerte
privilegio y el destino
termino de saldar destruir la
destrucción uno de los más importantes
yacimientos arqueológicos de estado la
tumba del señor de sipán un hallazgo que
en el hombro en su momento al mundo y
que fue lanzada por la revista de
national geographic como en tutankamón
del atunero
era sólo una tumba de un gobernante del
antiguo perú de una región luego
emperador pero el tesoro que logramos
encontrar en esta tumba que estaba a
punto de ser atacada no empañarán
solamente a los prospectos de oro
maravilloso y no era el conocimiento que
estamos recuperando sobre la forma de la
organización social el pensamiento
religioso el avance tecnológico que
había logrado y está en esta cultura
esto es lo que como se puede nombrar el
mundo
este fue mi primer reto porque la vida
está compuesta por lentos
el primer reto puedes salvar esta tumba
del parqueo y la construcción en medio
de una época relación saquear tumbas era
rumbas normal que hace un deporte
nacional los hacendados saqueado las
tumbas y estaba de tus puntos
la gente pobre cuando tenías algunas
necesidades de los monumentos para
saquear y vender lo que pudiendo
recuperar encontrará entonces había que
tratar de cómo despedir luchar cortar el
tráfico infame del experimento de
portugal
cuando se descubrió si pan se puso sobre
la mesa toda esta tragedia que ve a la
flor óptica un pasado extraordinario
como el perú con dificultades para su
conservación su difusión con limitación
de pocos deseos y decimos proyecto
también revertir
entonces hoy los resultados están a la
vista y pan forma parte una de las
páginas más importantes de la historia
de las culturas del perú hemos
construido un museo que le impide ya
estar desde su mejor acción hasta hoy
más de dos millones y medio de
visitantes
tenemos el sustento sólido de nuestra
identidad como peruana hoy la mayoría de
peruanos
se sienten herederos del señor de sipán
y saben que defienden de una cultura
espera un medio estamos entendiendo esa
otra mitad que estaba oculta bajo la
tierra los astrólogos hoy y esa región
ya no soy el único pero cerca de 60 que
trabajan de esta parte en perú se han
hecho nuevos descubrimientos nuevos
progresos pero yo soy el testigo de esta
época que hemos vivido imprevista
cambiando el pasado del perú me están
sustentando la identidad de los peruanos
el paso de perú ha permitido a rescatar
la autoestima de nuestra población
nativa el pasado de perú está impulsando
el desarrollo de una región
pero la respuesta que muchas veces me
hicieron en el pasado puede ser nuestro
futuro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]